Japan is set to unveil a hotel that replaces
room keys with facial recognition and replaces
humans with robots.
And researchers in Chile recently recorded
the velvet worm shooting a sticky web like
Spiderman.
It's a glue cannon.
Vsauce!
Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
The Digital Brain Library is slicing up and
preserving human brains.
Based in San Diego, this brain bank not only
slices human brains into micron-thin pieces,
but also digitizes them at extremely high
resolutions.
And this digital archive will be used to create
the Google Earth of the human brain.
Warka Water has developed a bamboo tower that
collects water from the air.
Designed for rural communities with limited
access to potable water, the Warka Tower stores
water from rain, dew, and fog.
The tower looks to be cheaper than current
water relief options so the hope is that it
will give rural villages stable access to
water.
The Lucid Pipe Power system is designed to
generate electricity with the help of your
sewage.
By installing turbines into existing waterlines
the Lucid Pipe generates clean energy by utilizing
the water flow that’s happening underground
anyway.
Unlike solar and wind energy it isn’t dependent
upon the weather as it takes advantage of
the day to day human activity.
This is a self-fueled liquid metal motor.
The drop of metal alloy is suspended in a
solution of sodium hydroxide and is fueled
by a flake of aluminum.
And this team is literally trying to make
intelligent robots that can change shape.
So yeah.
Researchers at University of California, Berkeley,
have managed to grow human heart cells on
a computer chip.
They’re grown from stem cells and surrounded
by micro fluid channels which supply them
with nutrients and drugs.
The heart cells could be modified to model
human genetic diseases and could eliminate
the need for the animal testing of drugs.
New Jersey is building the world’s largest
indoor vertical farm.
It’s currently under construction and plans
to grow two million pounds of food each year,
without soil.
The farm will use colored LEDS and nutrient-rich
liquid solutions to grow leafy greens as well
as herbs and spices, and represents a huge
step in urban farming.
The Voxel8 can 3D print electronics.
By utilizing an ink that’s over 5,000
times more conductive than current conductive
paste and filaments, the device can print
electronic parts that were previously impossible
to make.
The printers start shipping in late 2015,
but you can pre-order them now, so you can
start designing your 3D printed drone.
Researchers at MIT have developed a new way
to stimulate brain tissue with magnets.
By injecting magnetic iron oxide particles
into the brain, and then exposing them to
an alternating magnetic field, the particles
heat up and stimulate their surrounding brain
tissue.
This new method could revolutionize the way
neurological diseases like parkinson's are
treated.
And the procedure is wireless non-invasive,
and could be remote controlled.
H++ is developing interactive holographic
systems.
The holus will be a home appliance for interactive
holographic games and apps, and the Magic
Room will be a virtual interactive playspace
for children.
Finally, here’s the beta version of Tega
- one of the many social robots being developed
by the Personal Robots Group.
I’m going to leave you with a robot that
can balance on one foot while interacting
with humans.
And as always - thanks for watching.